can you get all the nutrition you need
from today's food or do you need to be
taking supplements while some people
swear by multivitamins others say they
either aren't effective or actually can
cause some harm makers of a vitamin pack
called 90 for life say their product
provides 90 essential nutrients for life
dr. Joel Wallach has a Bachelor of
Science and agriculture and a doctorate
in veterinary medicine from the
University of missouri-columbia in a
doctorate of naturopathic medicine from
the National College of naturopathic
medicine in Portland Oregon he was also
a nominee for the Nobel Prize in
medicine for his stunning discoveries in
the use of trace minerals to prevent
catastrophic diseases in newborns he's
also referred to as doc Wallach he
realized that traditional medicine was
very flawed in its focus on treatment
rather than focusing on preventing
disease through proper nutrition this
was something he learned and was
essential in veterinary medicine because
there is no health insurance for animals
striving to provide Americans with a new
view of Health and healing doc authored
dead doctors don't lie in the book tells
a story of doc walks journey to
discovering the importance of proper
nutrition and it goes into how
degenerative diseases are linked to
specific mineral and vitamin
deficiencies
he's also started a company called
youngevity that provides high quality
nutritional supplements to enrich your
quality of life at health way news.com
he's our guest on the show today he's
here to talk to us about health the
importance of proper nutrition and what
people can do to stay healthy we'll also
talk about the 90 for Life product
produced by youngevity in the value of
supplements welcome to the program doc
well thank you here I appreciate your
hospitality I'm happy to be here yeah
great to have you in the program let's
talk about the book dead doctors don't
lie it's pretty provocative title tell
us about it well basically the average
lifespan of medical doctors according to
their own survey which came out in 1999
is 56 and so why would anybody want to
listen to a group of people whose
average lifespan is 56 still it'd be a
hundred also this story came out in
February 5th 2007 and it was a big story
from the Institute of Medicine the
journal the American Medical Association
the Centers for Disease Control and they
said that medical doctors each year
there's a yearly figure kill injured in
fact 15 million patients at hospitals
and clinics across America alone can you
repeat that statistic one more time
please they kill injured in 15 million
patients and houses and Clinics each
year in America alone medical doctors
medical doctors do yes and so how many
people would flag commercial airlines a
thing that they killed injured infected
15 million people how many people go to
a fast food restaurant if they know they
killed injured infected fifteen million
customers and so I thought it was quite
interesting since the medical system has
been able to wiggle themselves into a
protective monopoly that is self
policing since 1914 following a report
called the flexion report and they're
totally unimpeachable they can kill with
impunity it seems and they get a walk
nobody even gets a parking ticket so so
dead doctors don't lie what's really the
basis for the book so you reveal those
those truths yes sir in your book and
then you go into some other topics oh
sure
well basically as you pointed out very
very well in veterinary medicine we
don't health have health insurance for
animals and a farmer is not going to pay
seventy eight thousand dollars for a hip
replacement for a ten thousand or bull
okay and so they learn how to regrow
cartilage we had to learn how to regrow
a heart would what a bull has congestive
heart failure we can deal with that in
five days it's a deficiency of a single
vitamin doctors like heart transplants
to make a quarter of a million dollars
when it should cost
couple bucks to deal with congestive
heart failure
things like Al's ham disease I said in
1993 when the original dead doctor don't
lie audio cassette tape came out in 1993
and Allisyn disease was a physician
cause disease actually caused by
deficiencies of nutrients rather than a
genetically transmitted disease as
doctors said and of course had set off a
firestorm and really brought us
to level or nationally looked at so in
your view you see that most diseases are
essentially the result of a deficiency
of a mineral or a vitamin now to be
treated by simply taking the supplement
there's most cases in most case it can
be prevented or reversed with
nutritional supplements that includes
Omega threes amino acids vitamins
minerals for instance there's not a
single birth defect that's caused by
genetic problems although doctors say
all jane holl burns the effects are
caused by genetic problems and there's
not a single one you have to appreciate
carry that over the thousands of years
that there's been philosophers and
physicians and medical doctors there's
thousands of failed medical theories and
the most recent one we're living to
right now is a failed medical theory
that all diseases are caused by bad
genes and if they could just build a
good gene Tecla engineer one replace the
bad gene with a good one everything be
fine
there's not a single disease as
genetically transmitted and so we're
living through kind of the end of this
time where everybody thought that every
disease was caused by bad genes
it's called epigenetics epigenetics is a
term given to the process by which your
DNA and your genes require certain
nutrients to maximize their genetic
potential numbers let's say we have the
potential to live 200 years which is
going to be 45 years because you don't
give your genes the raw materials they
need to get to the 200 year mark and so
that's where after there's not a skull
disease is caused by genes it's actually
all nutritional deficiencies now doc if
somebody is says well I eat a healthy
diet is it necessary for them to take
supplements absolutely impossible to
have an adequate diet eating healthy
there's two reasons for that Gary number
one the three o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 on Pearl
Street New York City on the bluff
overlooking the construction of the
Brooklyn Bridge Thomas Edison pulled the
switch on the first commercial electric
generating plant within ten years every
town every municipality in every city
the industrialized world converted from
what is universal fuel into electricity
well wood was our source of nutritional
minerals for thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of years because
the ashes aren't really ashes their
minerals are left when you burn in the
wood for fuel you would throw these
Merrill they k-8 wood ash it into the
garden the corn and the beans and
tomatoes and the sweet potatoes and
onions would soak up those minerals
you'd eat them and you get your minerals
in that fashion once we went to
electricity
nobody replaced that traditional source
of mineral nutrients secondly we began
to dam up the big rivers for two reason
number one people complained about
flooding in the cities then secondly
they needed more electricity because of
the demand for electricity grew well
when it would flood every year the flood
would leave silt and mud in the fields
which are a source of minerals from
mountains hundreds of miles away and the
farmers would plow that back in so the
meril source is renewed into the fields
every year by flooding and every day at
least in the rows near the farmers house
by throwing a wood ashes out into the
garden
both those sources their traditional
sources and nutritional minerals went
away and here come the medical doctors
don't you dare take vitamins and metals
you can overdose you know and so that
between the respected person telling
people not to take supplements our
sources of traditional minerals going
away because wood ash is one of a
because of our electricity use and
damming up the rivers so we no longer
got flooding we're in big trouble so
some people would would argue you know I
supplements are too expensive I already
eat healthy what do you say to people
who feel that supplements are just too
expensive to death is very expensive
your disease is very expensive I'll give
you a couple of examples you look at a
preemie for the three months from the
hospital costs on the average this was
just a cover story in Time magazine it
cost two hundred eighty thousand dollars
for premium for three months on the
average home cost $500,000 but on the
average is two hundred eighty thousand
some of them caused one hundred and
fifty thousand but on the average two
hundred eighty thousand for twelve
hundred dollars were the supplements for
the nine months of pregnancy they'll
never be another preemie
simple we've done that in the animal
industry because you can imagine a
farmer having to put preemie calves and
an incubator for 3 months your hamburger
cost you five hundred dollars a pound
just to pay her for the preemie care for
calves and secondly let's look at things
like very simple stuff like Jordan
placements and hip replacement in
America cause $78,000 deals is one joint
doesn't deal with the other 71 joins the
body our program for supporting and
promoting maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons joints if
you will backs it would cost for a
200-pound man big fellow like yourself
would cost say $1,500 for three months
$1,500 and after that $250 a month for
maintenance as opposed to seventy eight
thousand dollars the thing that's broken
America financially is the high cost of
ineffective dangerous medical treatments
okay and so it's much better to use
supplements that it is to do surgery and
of course it's medical doctors who say
the supplements are dangerous well in
2007 gearing the FDA finally submitted
to the pressure of the pharmaceutical
industry and doctors and reported the
first time for the first time ever the
very important so we'd be coming in for
people saying I got diarrhea but take
too much vitamin C I got itchy skin from
taking too much niacin and I got
headaches from taking some of those
herbs that are in energy drinks my heart
really went fast I went to the emergency
room 600 reports
adverse event reports at home in 2007
reported in 2008 for herbs vitamins and
minerals 600 adverse events reports 400
or in herbs and 200 in vitamins minerals
the same year 2007 report in 2008 it was
just short of 500,000 adverse event
reports for prescribe pharmaceuticals
five hundred thousand versus six hundred
and of course most of the five hundred
thousand were deaths
none of the nutritional or herbal
hazardous events reports for deaths now
those are pretty shocking figures when
you look at the the natural supplement
versus the the Big Pharma medications
over-the-counter drugs so when
somebody's going into the store and they
they see that the lines of vitamins how
do they make an informed choice is
there's so many companies there's so
many so many choices out there first of
all what before we get into that
specifically what are some of the the
key you have ninety four life is your
program but what are some of the would
you say top ten vitamins that are that
that people really need to focus on well
first of all mmm-hmm your her cake
recipe
Gary no I have not you had never heard
of a cake recipe Oh a cake recipe I'm
sorry I thought you mentioned a name I
think Kate recio's I'm sorry I don't
know who that is
okay okay Crespi of course let's say
it's 25 ingredients what if you just
take the further the ten you like and
leave out the other 15 you're not gonna
have a very good cake right it's gonna
be a pancake it's gonna taste awful or
it's gonna be gritty or there's it's not
gonna be right and so we like to talk
about all the known essential nutrients
okay we're gonna assume you're gonna get
a smattering of this and that and but
it's not going to be you tomato from the
same garden every day but one tomato
might have ten of those nutrient and the
next minute has three and so on and it's
not very predictable we're supposed to
be the high end of the intelligence
change so let's take all 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamins 1200
no acids three essential fatty acids so
to get the complete cake recipe you need
all 90 and so I I'm always reluctant to
pick out the top 10 of any one thing and
when you look at the top multiples on
the market regardless brand you're
looking at 28 to 30 nutrients in there
maybe 13 minerals well what about the
other 47 on the average each mineral
gives you and if
Chansey will give you anywhere from 10
to 25 diseases calcium deficiency alone
gives you a hundred and forty seven
different diseases then when you look at
you go to a health store or health food
store or you go to a grocery or a
pharmacy
they'll have vitamin A vitamin C calcium
magnesium zinc and if you if you buy a
$10 bottle of these nutrients and you
have to get 72 bottles to get each of
your nutrients you're looking at 720
dollars for a month okay so we've gotten
it down to be using natural products and
we test everything to make sure each
batch has all 90 essential nutrients and
optimal amounts for for a hundred and
twenty pound person that's going to cost
them something like two bucks a day for
a 200-pound person this could cost you
maybe five dollars a day and that's
going to support promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissues muscle heart lungs
liver kidneys brain eyes and myself this
month using the Chinese numbers I've
turned 75 and I haven't been to a doctor
with me being the patient for 68 years
been taking the 90 essential nutrients
twice a day for 68 years never been a
prescription medication my high blood
pressure is 90 over 60
my pulse is 43 which is a little high
for me as normally 38 as my pulse and I
can go to a pharmacy without a
prescription by all the test strips that
a doctor will use in a physical in his
office for a buck 50 a test strip and
all my numbers right dead center of
normal I've been doing this for 68 years
and if everybody does this the medical
system be real humbled and so that's my
job is to teach people to use all 90
essential nutrients is very economical
one hundred and fifty dollars a month
instead of 750 you can't buy individual
nutrients and put them - it's too
expensive and the average person will
say well I'll leave this one I'll just
take the top ten and I hope I'll get the
others out of my food it's actually
insane to do that when a dog food has
their
you know our babies formulas for
instance Gary have something like 13
minerals where's the other 47 or and the
food chemistry Journal came out in April
of 2012 and said baby formulas were very
familiar with I mean very well respected
baby farm was have less than 20% of the
minerals and less than 20% of the
vitamins or babies need dog food has
100% laboratory rat food has
hundred-percent chicken food has under
present and our kids have less than 20%
during the break where we were talking
briefly about scurvy and tell us about
the history of that and how that was was
essentially cured
okay well scurvy of course is a very
famous very important historical disease
more than two million British and
Japanese soldiers died over a hundred
year period from scurvy because as they
would go on these long sea voyages they
didn't have anything fresh to eat they
would eat salted pork and that sort of
thing but they didn't have cabbage they
didn't have fresh fruit green things to
eat and so vitamin C which when you're
deficient in vitamin C and scurvy and so
they didn't have an adequate source of
vitamin C and after 90 days at sea
they're all coming down their teeth are
falling out their bones are falling
apart connective tissues falling apart
of the hemorrhage to death and it costs
the British Navy and the Japanese Navy
enormous sums of money plus the lives of
these sailors and of course a lot of the
whole wanted to play how long did it
plug these navies Oh several hundred
years okay and of course the medical
doctors that time are looking for the
germ you have some grandmother say well
just let each sailor take a head of
cabbage with them or a basket of fruit
and it won't happen well where's the
germ lady there's got to be a germ
because this is one of those failed
medical theories where they thought they
fought Louis Pasteur
for a hundred years right his theory of
the germ theory because he's the one
that came up with insurance area pasture
he was a wine chemist and he was only a
wine chemist and we doctors know that
all diseases are
caused by things like or for humors are
out of balance or spontaneous generation
there's no such things as germs
well Vaughn Lewin hope the guy who came
up with a microscope and Pam sure can
see these germs and he could take pus
from somebody or sputum from somebody
there's a head pneumonia or dying and
injected into an animal and cause the
same disease and so he knew these little
bugs called germs you can see on the
microscope cause disease and he came up
with a germ theory and medical doctors
fought him even long after he died once
they believed in germs and everything
including every nutritional disease you
can think of including scurvy and
beriberi and pellagra and so forth were
all caused by germs and millions of
people died because they kept looking
for the germ and disregarded what
grandma said about eating more fresh
fruits and vegetables now there's
there's a hot hot debate about cancer
and its causes and your research over
time have you discovered that cancer is
also of the cause of a vitamin
deficiency
well there's many things we know about
cancer a number one and this is one of
my lawsuits against the FDA and I
prevailed in federal courts to be able
to say that you can prevent or reduce
the risk of many different cancers by
supplementing with 200 micrograms a day
of the tradesmen or selenium reduce the
risk of certain cancers like breast
cancer by 82% prostate cancer by 69% and
breast cancer by 32% just by
supplementing with 200 micrograms of
selenium you can also reduce the risk of
breast cancer by four hundred and sixty
two percent by just cooking or meat
medium-rare instead of well-done the
cancer bullseye in America is Jackson
Mississippi now when you look at the
cancer rate or across the United States
the worst place to be in America for
cancer is Jackson Mississippi why is
that well that's because they fry
everything there there's rumors they
even fry water we know they fry ice
cream and fried water and fried foods
cause trans fatty acids head of psychic
domains and acrylamide these are
chemicals far more dangerous than
anything that Monsanto and Dow Chemical
and eating fried foods causes cancer
people have to come to grips with this
and of course this goes along with the
study from the University of South
Carolina which came out in 1998 well let
me just jump in there real quick I love
fried foods is there do you have a
supplement that I could take that I
could still eat my fried foods I
wouldn't suggest that but we do know
that antioxidants which will reduce the
level of free radical damage you're
gonna have to eat a hundred thousand or
act points an hour okay they were to
compensate for eating fried foods
I just wouldn't play with that it's like
playing with a loaded gun pointed
yourself and pulling trigger and say
well there's only one shell in there BAM
you know you're dead the same thing is I
wouldn't give anybody permission to take
more antioxidants than you fried foods I
just I don't do it you're gonna get some
protection but I've known people who
have tried it and they didn't do well
and so I wouldn't suggest it so what
makes your product your vitamin
supplements you're ninety for Life
program what sets it apart from from the
pack you know are all supplements
created equal is the question well the
questions answer of course is that no
not all supplements are created equal
for instance what makes me different you
said it very well at the beginning I
have degree in agriculture I have a
degree in veterinary medicine when you
left out the fact that I do have also a
postdoc and compared pathology ready to
autopsies and animals and people and
this is before I became at an HP ethic
physician and in one study I did over
20,000 autopsies at the Center for the
biology of natural systems of Washington
University at the st. Louis Zoo and the
jaws of mechanical gardens in st. Louis
in the 60s and 70s and the book that
came out of that 1,200 pages as in the
Smithsonian Institute as a national
treasure the bottom line of this study
was that is 454 species of zoo animals
3,000 human 17,000 some changed what
were 454 species of animals 10 million
chemistry's is in a book that thick and
the bottom line of the study Gary was
that every animal in every human being
that dies of what we would call natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
disease if you ask a medical doctor
all the rare-earths which doubled
lifespans of laboratory animals in
double-blind randomized studies they
can't name you one they didn't know what
a rare-earth is these are substances for
our audience's benefit what is a
rare-earth Oh Kayla rare-earth is a
trace trace trace mineral you need say a
thousand times less of ytterbium
nutriyum neodymium proxy odium then you
do selenium or magnesium or chromium or
vanadium and but they're essential for
maximize your genetic potential for
longevity and health ok we'll double the
lifespan of laboratory animals and so
why not be aware of those make sure
you're taking adequate amounts to make
your genes your DNA happy ok well if a
doctor doesn't even know they exist
because all he knows about is calcium
and magnesium and some potassium and
otherwise they're extremely ignorant and
that's why only dead doctors don't lie
so what conditions give bodies the best
chance to heal themselves so we don't
have to go to the to the dead doctor and
get you get a pharmaceutical
prescription and which is comes along
with multiple side effects sure well
first of all you have to appreciate Gary
with the exception of antibiotics which
do cure syphilis and bikes will cure
strep throat bacterial meningitis
gangrene these sorts of things like with
the exception of antibiotics which is
about 500m in the physicians Desk
Reference there's not a single
pharmaceutical that's prescribed by
medical doctors to cure anything they
all relieve symptoms there's no law
requiring a doctor to cure you when
there's a cure available for instance
rheumatoid arthritis is curable in two
weeks why would a doctor want to make
$300 in office calls by curing you of
your rheumatoid arthritis in two or
three weeks when you can make seven
hundred and fifty thousand dollars by
treating you for 25 years insurance pays
why worry about it and there are there
philosophies so rheumatoid arthritis is
a major problem in America a lot of
people watching this right now are
suffering yes
what mineral supplements would you say
that individual could take to alleviate
some of that
some of that that problem that disease
well rheumatoid arthritis Gary has it is
two parts number one the actual disease
is different from bone to bone or
arthritis or osteoarthritis or
osteopenia and osteoporosis which is
simply a nutritional deficiency okay
room which arthritis is a combination of
a nutritional deficiency and an
infection with a bug called mycoplasma
and there's a tetracycline called
minocycline as a member of the
tetracycline family and i can kill that
bug in two weeks with minocycline and
kill the micro plasma in two weeks so it
kills the infection just like it can
kill the syphilis bacteria with
penicillin in two weeks just same
concept no big deal but then you have
the damage that that bacteria did to the
joints joint capsule tendons and
ligaments and deficiencies the
complicated things by causing all kinds
of deformities well we have a program we
call the healthy bone and joint pack
which has all 90 essential nutrients
plus what we call the secret sauce for
supporting and promoting maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue joint capsules discs
between the vertebrae all the things
that are damaged by this infection and
so all the drugs that are sold on TV or
the doctor might prescribe for your
fruit which arthritis gold shots
methotrexate and some of the
pharmaceuticals which I'm not going to
name only relieve symptoms
none of them kill the bug none of them
rebuild anything they relieve pain and
inflammation and so over time the
infection and the degenerative disease
gets worse and worse and worse then you
have joint replacements and this is
where the big expense comes in 780
thousand dollars for each hip that's a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars for
two hips and the knee replacements and
the finger replacements and four joints
and the fingers and in the back of the
hand the wrist the elbow the shoulders
and so it gets pretty scary but doctors
know that each room tries to try his
patient is money in the bank they just
draw on that deposit anytime they need
the money
kids going into Harvard hey come on in
Frank I have a brand new hip I'm going
to try on you I'm gonna give you a
discount on it Frank comes in
charge the guy who's $78,000 an
insurance company sounds like sounds
like a like a bit of a racket to me it
is a racket what other industry can kill
injured in fact 15 million of their
customers our workplace every year and
still be in business year after year
after year let's talk about exercise
four okay and just how important is
exercise compared to vitamins for good
general health there is no comparison if
you have a choice of taking all 90
essential nutrients and exercise take
the 997 nutrients skip the exercise
exercise of the supplementation is a
fatal fatal fatal disease but you think
about it during you take all the
professional sports combined the average
lifespan professional athletes is 62
football players is 51 there has never
been a professional athlete ever lived
to be 100 so what's so good about
exercise in fact in December of nineteen
eighty-two the journal the American
Medical Association came out of a little
study that said while running a man's
risk of heart attack death increases by
700 percent so why would anybody want to
run okay if you're gonna run you better
be supplementing heavily and so we came
up with a sports drink that has a
hundred nutrients in it replacing
everything that's in your sweat most
sports drinks have either two four or
six nutrients in it ours has 100 because
sweat is not water so what is a soup
though of everything floating around
your blood so you have a sports drink as
well yes and how does that compare to
the stuff that we find in the gas
station refrigerator
well again depending on the brand they
might have two nutrients you might have
for nutrients or six nutrients how do
you compare two four six nutrition to
the hundred nutrients and your sweats
can obtain any content your sweat is
going to contain anywhere between say 65
and 90 nutrients depending off your
supplementing or not if you just drink
water to rehydrate yourself you'll
rehydrate yourself but your knees will
break down because you're not getting
enough nutrients to replace what you're
losing through the sweat you might get
muscle cramps you're getting up muscle
tears you're going to
get a sudden heart death like a lot of
10,000 young athletes every year in
America died from sudden heart death
this is due to a deficiency of a single
mineral selenium ruptured aneurysms
while running because the death of many
young athletes and this has gotta bend
officials you have another single
mineral copper well there's no with the
exception of our sport shrink there's no
other sports drink that has copper and
selenium and they all have just sodium
and chloride okay now what about
children you know we've seen the little
gummies that they've kids can have and
and those types of things so how
important is supplement for a growing
child well a grown child needs more
vitamins minerals per pound of body
weight than an adult like you and me
we're maintaining ourselves right we
just want to maximize our genetic
potential for longevity and health well
these kids now here they look at that
requirement but also they're looking at
growth and puberty and all the other
special pressures that are put on their
systems and so per pound of body weight
and youngster needs far more nutrients
each day than we do for maintenance per
pound of body weight so and again in
April of 2012 and food chemistry general
said that are very well respected baby
foods baby formulas contain less than
20% of the minerals and vitamins that
our babies need so we have an insane
system in fact a cover story Time
magazine in December of 2008 came out
and said that our children and I can
live as long as us or our kids are the
first generation they're not gonna live
as long as the parents the parent many
parents will be burying their children
because they're not getting the
nutrition then we got assembly because
there's no more wood ashes going into
the garden we've damned if the river is
no more silt coming in in the floods
every year and then here's the doctrine
as white-coat saying up don't you
supplement Gary it's bad for you can
overdose you know well doc we're coming
up to the end of the under the the clock
here and I want to ask you one last
question yes sir what do you think are
the leading causes of the healthcare
crisis in the United States
well the main causes the medical system
has been made into a
a monopoly is monopoly is self-policing
they have been able to render all their
competition as quacks insurance only
pays them and any industry that can kill
injure in fact 15 million customers our
workplace every year and still be in
business next year or next month or next
week is an amazing industry we need to
think about it
they also infect two million people each
year in hostels alone of which 90,000
died
what if Iran or North Korea would her
sent over a biological weapon
intercontinental ballistic missile and
killed 90 thousand people and in fact
two million at a large population center
we declare war on them here's one trade
that does it every year in the workplace
nobody seems to care that's the biggest
problem they don't have any competition
if you're gonna put a roof on your house
Gary or put a sprinkler system yard
you're gonna get five bids you're gonna
find out from something like Better
Business Bureau or one of these things
online who's the best one and you're
going to find if there's any complaints
about them people go to the same doctor
for twenty five thirty forty years
whatever the doctor says they do without
even checking with another doctor those
that's the main problem if there's one
thing you want our audience to take away
from today from this interview we've
covered so much ground here I wish we
had more time because we could keep on
going I know we could but if there's one
thing you really want our audience to
take away from today what would that be
did they must supplement with the 90
essential nutrients and do it
obsessively I've done four twice a day
for 68 years been blessed of perfect
health if everybody were like me
health-wise guess what Gary the medical
system would be really really unhappy
and what do you think would happen with
Obamacare oh well
Obamacare is problematic simply because
it failed thinking that the reason why
America is sick is because they didn't
have access to doctors Obamacare is like
putting people on the furnace so having
the supplements would prevent that from
happening because you put sick
kourt's oil in your car prevent the
engine from running up do you put the
six quarts of oil in your car after the
engine burns up or before the engine
burns up so you take the 90 descent
solutions before you get sick you just
don't get sick
[Music]